I
[Silence]
Thank you all, brothers and sisters,
guests. Thank you for joining us today
or this evening
on the newest installment of Zad
al-Ma'ad fi Hadyi Khair al-Ibad,
authored by the late and great esteemed
scholar of Islam
Ibn Qayyim al-Jawziyyah, Shams al-Din,
rahimahullah ta'ala.
We left off
last week
discussing
the way that the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam would make wudu
and the way that he would make wudu
based on whatever he was wearing,
especially what a person is wearing on
his head,
what a person is wearing on his feet.
A person
to
wear footwear,
we mentioned that there are
certain things that
a person can wipe over when they are
wearing something on their feet. And
we've gotten into that in great detail.
Likewise, the head.
We see an example that the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam
wiped over his turban, right?
And we see an example that the wives of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
such as Salamah and others,
they would wipe over their
scarves or their head garments, their
hijab,
so to speak.
And we mentioned that there is a happy
medium
between what a person is to wipe over
with regards to headwear.
If a person is wearing something that
would be
a significant annoyance to remove,
then a person would merely wipe over it,
a turban, a hijab, like
something that needs to be wrapped or
something elaborate or something.
But if a person is just wearing a cap or
a hat, this would not fall into that
category in the correct opinion of the
scholars of Islam.
Now I'd to transition on to another
topic, which is the alternative
to wudu.
And that is a tayammum.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala gives us two
options in the Quran.
He gives us two alternatives. He says,
[Arabic recitation]
He says, Wa in kuntum 'ala safarin falam
tajidu maa'an fatayammamoo sa'eedan
tayyibah.
He says, "If you are traveling
and you do not have access to water,
then make tayammum."
Imam al-Shafi'i Rahimahullah, he makes a
very brilliant point with regards to
this verse.
So he says
that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala gave us
here two options.
We have water
or we have its alternative, which is a
tayammum.
So if a person does not have water,
specifically what is referred to as
water,
then the person would make tayammum,
even if they have other liquids at their
disposal.
What does that mean? Well, let's say a
person has access to water, they do not
have access to water, excuse me, but
they do have access to orange juice.
Would a person make wudu with orange
juice? The answer is no.
Because it is not water. What about
chicken broth? What about
anything that has left the realm of
being referred to as water?
Or it is referred to as something with
water.
Right?
Then this is no longer what Allah is
speaking about,
which is appropriate for us to make wudu
with.
Anything but water is not appropriate to
make wudu with.
So, if we do not have water,
then we are to make wudu
by we are to purify ourselves, prepare
ourselves for prayer
with tayammum.
What is tayammum?
Well, tayammum in the Arabic language
huwa al-qasd.
Tayammum in the Arabic language is
intention, what you are intending to do.
And what is meant by tayammum
legislatively in the legislation of
Islam
is that a person purify himself
from major or minor hadath,
meaning major or minor
in
major or minor type of state of
being
to make himself or herself
suitable to be able to pray.
And it is done by way of using dust.
Dust. What does that mean?
So, the way that tayammum works
in the correct opinion
is that it is a symbolic worship. Now,
if you don't have water, you're you are
to
make tayammum
and using this dust in place of water.
What does it do? Well, we we don't know.
It is a spiritual
cleansing.
And so, it's not necessarily anything
that we can detect
with our physical being, but it's
something that Allah has commanded.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Inna Allaha yahkumu ma yureed."
This is a very interesting verse
because this verse, "Inna Allaha yahkumu
ma yureed." Indeed, Allah does
command and judge and legislate what he
chooses.
This verse
is one of the beginning and opening
verses of Surat al-Ma'idah.
And Surat al-Ma'idah is the chapter
which has the verse of wudu in it
that we have been speaking so much
about.
Now, a person may say,
"Well, why? Why is it that a person
needs to make wudu in order to make
salah? Inna Allaha yahkumu ma yureed."
"Why is it that an alternative to using
water is to use dust? Inna Allaha
yahkumu ma yureed."
And so on and so forth. This mentality
of Allah legislates what he chooses
and my position as a slave is not to as
a servant of Allah is not to
is not necessarily to
understand everything, rather my
position is to obey everything.
Now, this doesn't mean that we don't try
to understand. Yes, we try to
understand.
Because every ruling of Allah, every
statement of Allah, every word of Allah,
everything that Allah does or legislates
is a reflection of who Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala is.
And so for us to look for the reasoning
behind things that Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala legislates or does,
this is part of learning who Allah is.
But not always can we understand or
learn
what that particular ruling
is based on, what portion of wisdom
it is based on.
How is Tayammum done?
Well, Ibn al-Qayyim Rahimahullah he
says,
[Arabic recitation]
sallam yata yammam bi dharbatin
wahidatin lil wajhi wal kaffayn.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
would make
Tayammum by
patting the ground or the surface one
time,
and that would be once for his face and
his hands.
What kind of What is Tayammum?
A person does not have water.
Or a person does not have access to
water.
Or a person has water, but they are
unable to use it, right?
So for example, a person there's no
water around,
or a person has a little bit of water,
just enough to drink,
and they are lost or they are in a
position where they can't use this
drinking water to make wudu.
Or there is water somewhere in some
outlandish place, and let's say there
is a a military compound that has
running water in it, but in order for me
to make wudu there I have to sneak in
and risk getting shot or get risk
getting arrested or something this.
So there's water, but I don't have
access to it.
Or let's say there is a well, but I have
no way of getting the water out of the
well. There's no bucket there, for
instance. These are all instances in
which a person has water,
they just don't have access to it.
Or a person has the water, has access to
it, but is unable to use it.
Whether that be because they are ill,
whether that be because it is bitterly
cold,
whether that be that the water is too
hot to use,
the water is
questionable that it may be poisonous or
something of the sort. In this case, a
person has water, but they do not have
the ability to use it.
So, we transition from that to a
tayammum.
And a tayammum is performed this.
I'm going to demonstrate it.
Now, pay attention. Don't blink because
you might miss it. Person says,
"Bismillah."
Pats the ground once,
right?
May blow on his hands if there's
something stuck to his hands that is,
you know, pebbles or something,
once.
Wipes the face,
and then the two hands.
That's tayammum.
That's it.
Nothing else. Only one time.
Not three times, not all the way up to
the arms, not into your beard. None of
the rulings of wudu in that sense.
It is the face first,
and then the two hands in the order in
which Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala mentions
the tayammum. He says, "Famsahu bi
[Arabic recitation]
And this is what is intended.
And so,
when a person goes to make wudu,
one pat, they say, "Bismillah." They
have the intention.
"Bismillah."
Once,
and that. That's it.
That is how wudu That is how tayammum is
made.
Now,
how do we know that it doesn't go up to
the arm, all the way up here? Because in
some of the Hadith, that is how it is.
Well, when we look through the texts of
the Quran,
we start to see that there is a pattern.
And that pattern is
whenever Allah mentions the hand in the
Quran,
unless otherwise specified, it is meant
from the tips of the fingers to the
wrist. That is the hand in the Quran.
Right?
In the Arabic language, al-yad
would entail all of this, from the tips
of the fingers all the way to the
shoulder.
This is all considered al-yad, all of
this. The forearm, the bicep, all of
that is part of the
the upper arm, all of that is part of
the yad in the Arabic language. But in
the Quran, we see that every time Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions al-yad, the
hand,
he is referring to
al-kaff.
He is referring to up to the wrist,
unless otherwise specified.
Unless Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala adds on
to that and says the hand up to the
shoulder, or the hand up to the elbow,
or the hand with the forearm, unless
that is mentioned, what is meant is only
to the wrist.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says with
regards to wudu,
wa aydiyakum ilal marafiq. When you make
wudu,
wash your hands up to and including the
elbows. But in the same verse, when he
speaks about tayamum, he only says,
[Arabic recitation]
Wipe your faces and your hands. So we
understand from this that what is meant
by the hand is only to the wrist. And
this is what we find in the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam Sunnah.
And so this would only be one time, not
three times,
not two times,
only once in that way that I have
described.
He says wayatayamam will be ard allati
you sallee alayha turaban kanat aw
sabakha aw ramlan.
He says and the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam would perform this
tayammum
from whatever the ground is that he is
going to pray pray on.
Whether that is dirt,
whether that is a kind of swampy,
marshy, mangrove kind of
terrain. It's usually where the a
large body of water meets the dirt or
the the the desert area and causes
this kind of mixture of terrain
or a raml or sand.
No matter what the ground is,
whether that be sand or marshy or dirt,
he would make tayammum from all of those
places.
Well, why is Ibn al-Qayyim saying this?
He's saying this because some scholars
of Islam have said tayammum can only be
done with dirt.
Tayammum can only be done with dirt and
this is not necessarily correct.
Rather, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam would make tayammum
from whatever piece of land he is on or
piece of ground he is upon when the time
of prayer comes.
In this spirit, the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam has been
reported to have said authentically,
"Haythuma adrakat rajulan min ummati
salatu fa inda
This narration has been collected by
Imam Ahmad on the authority of Abu
Umamah al-Bahili radiyallahu anhu
in which the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said in the full Hadith, I will
mention to you the full Hadith.
He says,
[Silence]
He said Sallallahu alayhi wasallam that
which translates to
the entirety of the earth
has been designated as a place of prayer
and as pure
for me and all of my nation to follow.
So, any individual from amongst my
nation
whom the time of salah enters upon
wherever he is,
he will always have his place of prayer
and what he can make tayammum from and
his purification.
So, that means if a person is in the
desert where it's only sand or if a
person is in a field where it's dirt or
if a person is in a marsh where it is
kind of sediment, wherever a person is,
regardless of where he is, he can make
tayammum from that or she.
And so, often times people don't
understand this.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave two
conditions to a sa'id,
to a tayammum.
He says, "Fa tayammamoo
ay fa tawajjahu li tayammum min
Fa tayammamoo sa'idan
tayyiban."
Two conditions.
Number one, it is sa'id. And a sa'id in
the Arabic language is anything that
rests on top of something else.
So, the dust that is on my desk now,
this is sa'id because it has rested on
top of it, right? He says, "Tayyiba."
That it has to be good and pure in
itself.
So, if it is something that is not good,
it is not pure, then a person cannot
make tayammum with it.
So, if it is something that is impure
and has dried, a person cannot make
tayammum with that, right? But, a person
can make tayammum from anything that is
pure and is sa'id. Whether that sa'id,
that thing that rests on top of the
earth be dirt or dust or
or it be
for example, sand on the beach,
right? All of this is acceptable for a
person to make tayammum with.
It's been narrated that the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam made
tayammum off of a wall.
A wall that he was
walking by. Of course, the wall would be
made out of
rocks or it would be made out of in
the time of the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, it would also be made
out of clay bricks, mud bricks. They
would take mud and they would dry this
mud bricks into the in the sun, and then
they would build their walls with it.
And so, these mud houses had to be
constantly
they had to be constantly
you know, looked after because obviously
every time it rains, it will wash off
some of the mud and weaken the house and
the structure. And this is what the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
masjid was made out of. It was made out
of mud.
And so, he was narrated to have made
wudu off of that wall.
Anything that
is dust
a person can make wudu with, make
tayammum with, excuse me.
So, often times when we go to visit
people in the hospital, they will have a
rock or a stone there
that they will make tayammum off of.
This is not necessary,
right?
Anywhere there's dust, the scholars have
even mentioned in more contemporary
times, dust off of a dashboard in a
vehicle.
This is all something which is
permissible for a person to
make tayammum off of. Let's say a person
drives down a
dirt gravel road, kicks up a bunch of
dust. You know, once you park the car,
the dust will have settled on the car
and if you were to wipe your hand across
it, it would wipe away some of the dust.
This is something a person can make
tayammum with.
And so,
Ibn al-Qayyim Rahimahullah says that
this is the correct opinion and this is
how the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam did it. Now, how do we know
that's how he did it?
Ibn al-Qayyim goes into the reasoning
behind
[Silence]
He says, "The reason that we know that
the Prophet
Alayhi Wasallam did make tayammum from
sand.
You know what? Sand is different than
dirt. It's not really dust. It is
actually little
fine finely grained
or finely ground
rocks essentially.
And so
Ibn al-Qayyim Rahimahullah, he says, "We
know for a fact that he made tayammum
from sand.
He says, "And the reason that we know
this is that when he and his companions
would go to very long distances
for battle or in journey, such as the
Battle of Tabuk
in which they traveled for weeks to
reach where they were going in the time
of
in a time of extreme heat in the desert.
He says,
"They would travel all of those
extensive distances
over sand and they had very very little
water with them.
Their water was just enough to survive,
just enough to keep them alive
in those deserts. And the desert is all
sand.
He says, "And it has not ever been
narrated that he carried any dirt along
with him on this journey.
Nor did he tell anybody else to carry
dirt with him.
Nor did any of his companions
have ever been narrated to have carried
dirt when they are traveling across the
desert because the desert has no dirt,
it is only sand.
He says, "And whoever really thinks
about these circumstances will come to
the total
total and certain conclusion
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would make tayammum
with sand.
He says, "And it has not been narrated
nor had it it has not been authentically
narrated that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would make tayammum for
each salah
nor would he command others to do so."
Rather, he would make tayammum and this
tayammum under those circumstances in
which tayammum is is valid, the
circumstances that we mentioned.
He
considered tayammum to be the equivalent
of wudu under those circumstances. Now,
why is Ibnul Qayyim saying this?
Well, he's saying this because
in some of the madhahib of the scholars
of Islam, a person can make tayammum
for let's say a person is in the desert
or in in a in a set of circumstances
where tayammum would be valid.
And
this individual
is under these circumstances for
dhuhr and asr and maghrib and isha.
Well, in the opinion of some scholars of
Islam
a person can make tayammum for dhuhr
but when asr comes in, they have to make
tayammum again.
And when maghrib comes in, they have to
make tayammum again
for each prayer.
And that is not correct. Rather tayammum
is the equivalent of wudu under the
circumstances in which tayammum is
valid. The circumstances that we
mentioned.
So, a person can make tayammum at Dhuhr
and now he has the same rulings as wudu
until he no longer is under a set of
circumstances
in which tayammum is valid. So, for
example,
the person makes tayammum for Dhuhr.
And now they have tayammum. They have
They have essentially wudu.
The only thing that will break that
tayammum is what would break wudu,
right?
Such as passing gas or any of the things
that would break wudu.
This will continue on into Asr, Maghrib,
Isha. The only time that tayammum is
invalidated
is one,
something that invalidates wudu occurs,
such as passing gas or
you know, breaking wind or urinating or
any of those things.
Or two, the circumstances under which
tayammum is valid are no longer present.
This is where people get the very
popular adage in the Arabic language,
"Idha hadara al-ma' batala al-tayammum."
And this is correct.
And that is that
if water becomes available,
then tayammum is no longer valid.
Right?
What invalidates wudu? In order for us
to know what invalidates tayammum, we
have to know what invalidates wudu.
Well,
what invalidates wudu
is anything passing through the two
private parts. Number one. So,
anything that comes or is excreted from
the from the front, from the urinary
tract, or from the rear, from the
rectum. Any of these things, anything
coming out, al-kharij min al-sabilayn.
This is something that will invalidate a
person's wudu.
Number two
is
an individual falls into a deep sleep.
What is meant by deep sleep?
So, the scholars of Islam have mentioned
the definition of deep sleep.
Deep sleep
is when a person is no longer aware
of what is going around going on around
him in his immediate environment.
What does that mean?
Well, have you ever fallen asleep,
lightly fallen asleep, and
what people are saying around you
incorporates itself into what you're
dreaming?
Or you fallen asleep, but any movement
or anything that would happen, you would
wake up, a very light sleep, regardless
of the position you're in.
This will not invalidate your wudu.
What invalidates a person's wudu is
sleep that causes loss of consciousness.
Complete sleep.
Why?
It is not because sleep itself
invalidates wudu.
It is because sleep is likely that a
person will
lose his wudu and he not know about it.
It is madhannah.
Al-hadath. It is not hadath in itself,
it is madhannah to al-hadath. As the
scholars of fiqh have mentioned.
How do we know this?
In some madhahib, they get into the
issue of the position that you're
sitting in.
If you're sitting upright,
and your and a person's bottom is flat
on the ground, then they say, "Even if
your sleep is deep, then your wudu is
intact."
But if a person is laying down, even if
your
sleep is light, then your wudu is
invalidated. And that's not really the
heart of the issue.
The heart of the issue is whether a
person would sense
if he had broken his wudu or not.
That is really where it is.
So, sleeping itself
does not invalidate a person's wudu. The
problem with sleeping
is that it causes you to lose awareness
of what your body is doing.
If you lose awareness of what your body
is doing,
you may pass wind, break wind, pass gas,
and you don't even know about it.
This is why when a person sleeps deeply
enough
in to which a person cannot sense what
his body is doing, if if you were
sleeping and I were to touch your hand
very very lightly and you wake up,
this is something that your wudu is
valid.
If you fall asleep so deeply that I'm
shaking you and you're not waking up,
this wudu has become invalidated.
Because this person cannot feel, cannot
sense what is happening to him.
And so,
in order for us to understand this, we
have to understand where we get this
from.
The original statement of the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, which is
collected in a Sunan on the authority of
Ali ibn Abi Talib radiyallahu anhu,
that the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said,
He says, "The eye
is essentially the gatekeeper
of a sa, which is
a person's
essentially in in easier terms
person's bowel movements or person if he
passes wind.
Once the eye closes, a person doesn't
know what happens after this. Closes
meaning in sleep.
He says so whoever falls asleep then he
has to make will do.
But then we see that Anas ibn Malik
narrates
in Bukhari and Muslim
that the companions of the Prophet
alayhi wasallam would often wait
after making Salat al-Maghrib
to make Salat al-Ishaa.
Why? Well, we have to understand the
time.
The time is is that
everything is dark. There are no street
lights. There are no lights inside of
the masjid. There are no lights in
people's houses only little fires here
and there or candles or something.
And so
between Maghrib and Ishaa the masjid is
very dark inside. You You won't even
know who is standing or sitting beside
you unless they speak to you.
And this is why this is the secret
behind
why the Prophet
alayhi wasallam mentioned that the two
prayers that the hypocrites cannot
attend meaning that they are
least likely to attend are the prayers
of Fajr and Ishaa.
Why is that? Well,
because at Fajr time
at the break of dawn and at the night
time at Ishaa the masjid is so dark that
nobody would notice if they weren't
present. And a hypocrite is only praying
in order that he be seen. If he's not
seen then he's not going to pray.
And so they would be most likely to
be absent during the Fajr and Isha
salah.
The reason for that is that
nobody would notice if they weren't
present.
Just the hypocrites
are most likely in the time of the
prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
they are least likely to attend major
battles such as the Ghazwa of Tabuk
because the numbers were so many they
thought that
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
wouldn't notice if we weren't present. A
caravan is miles long. So
they they figured there's so many people
they wouldn't even notice if we were
absent, right?
And so when you have that the companions
have all
works all day and now they're finally
coming into the masjid, the sun has set
it's dark, the masjid is dark, they're
sitting in the masjid waiting
it's become cool
right? Because it's usually very hot,
very inhospitable to sleep. Now
the masjid is very cool, very
comfortable, right? Relatively.
People would start falling asleep
waiting between Maghrib and Isha. Anas
ibn Malik radiyallahu anhu said people
would fall asleep between Maghrib and
Isha sitting up and their chins would be
on their chests, meaning they're sitting
up but they are
sleeping this.
Now what's important is that Anas
mentions that when the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam would emerge
in order to lead them in salat and Isha
the companions
Abu Bakr, Umar, Abu Hurayrah, Uthman,
you know, al-Bara' ibn Azib, al-Zubayr
ibn al-Awwam, these Ali ibn Abi Talib,
these great scholars of Islam, Abu Musa
al-Ash'ari,
Abdullah ibn Umar, Abdullah ibn
Mas'ud, all of these scholars,
they would be there.
When he would come out, they would just
stand up. They would not go and make
wudu again, and they would pray.
Why?
Well, we take from this that the
companions understood that sleep itself
does not invalidate a person's wudu.
What invalidates a person's wudu is loss
of consciousness
to the point that you don't know what
your body is doing. You wouldn't sense
it if you had fallen asleep.
And so,
regardless of the position, that's not
what import what is important. What is
important is deep sleep
will invalidate your wudu.
So, now we have two things that
invalidate wudu. Al-kharij min
al-sabilayn, anything that exits the two
private parts,
male or female.
Number two, deep sleep.
Number three,
loss of consciousness.
Because this has the same ruling of
sleep, deep sleep. Loss of
consciousness.
Number four,
eating the meat
of camels.
Which is something that in America 99.9%
of us is never going to encounter,
right? Unless you go to Hajj or Umrah or
go to one of these exotic countries and
happen to eat camel meat. I grew up in
the in the East, the Arab countries.
I've never tasted it. I've never even
seen it.
So,
anyways,
these things invalidate a person's wudu.
If these things do not occur, these
things which invalidate a person's wudu,
if these things do not occur,
then they do not invalidate his wudu,
and they as well go for tayammum. They
will not invalidate his or her tayammum.
And so,
the things that invalidate a person's
wudu are very specific things,
right?
One of the things, another one of the
things that some of the scholars mention
will invalidate a person's wudu
is touching someone of the opposite sex,
one skin-on-skin contact.
The scholars differ on this.
Well,
the correct opinion is no matter what a
person, who a person touches, his wife,
whoever it is of the opposite sex,
as long as nothing is excreted from
the private parts upon doing so, the
person's wudu is valid.
Likewise, another thing that people
mention, or some scholars mention, is
vomiting,
right? That if a person vomits,
either willingly or unwillingly,
that this will invalidate a person's
wudu. And this is
as well not as correct.
we do have a narration in a sunan in
which the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam made himself to vomit, and then
he made wudu.
And
the actions of the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam alone
do not articulate obligation in the
correct opinion.
So, we understand from this that it is
better that if a person vomits, that he
makes wudu, but it's not necessary,
right?
It is not something which is an
obligation. It does not invalidate your
wudu.
And so,
wudu and tayammum have the same rulings
in this regard.
[Arabic recitation]
alayhi wasallam would make wudu. This is
how he would make tayammum and these are
the rulings of both tayammum and wudu.
Tayammum is a little bit special in the
sense that it as well will take the
place of
al-ghusl.
So, if a person is in a state of
janabah, which is sexual impurity,
or
a woman who is in a state of
menstruation or postpartum bleeding, it
is over al-hayd wal-nifas,
it's over, she's no longer in that
state, before she can
pray, before she can have wudu, she has
to bathe.
Right?
But, if you do not have access under
these circumstances
to water or you have access to it, but
you cannot or you do not have access to
it or you do not have water or you are
unable to use accessible water,
then tayammum takes the place of
al-ghusl as well.
Right? So, a person makes tayammum and
now they can pray and recite Quran and
they have ghusl. They are no longer in a
state of janabah.
One thing that Ibn al-Qayyim
rahimahullah did not mention
in this chapter and that is how the
[Arabic recitation]
make ghusl, how he would bathe.
Now, this is a whole other thing because
bathing
has many rulings and many, many people
are very
unclear as to regard as to these
rulings, how they are implemented.
I'm going to describe to you now how the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam would make ghusl.
After this, I'm going to describe to you
the bare minimum of ghusl.
And so, Aisha radiyallahu anha narrates
in Sahih Muslim
that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam would make ghusl in the
following way.
He would begin by
yadliku yadaihi. He would wash his
hands.
Right?
After washing his hands three times,
he would then wash his private parts,
front and back.
After this, he would make wudu as if he
is making wudu for salah.
Right? So, he would go through the
motions, wash his hands, mouth, nose,
face, everything that we've described.
And then, he would either wash his feet
as well or he would wait and hold off on
his feet. So, he'd wipe over his head
and his ears, and then,
he would pour the water on his head
three times
and work the water into his scalp.
After this, he would wash the right side
of his body, every part,
and then he would wash the left side of
his body.
After this, he would wash his feet, and
that would be ghusl.
Now,
why did he wash his feet? We have now
drains
that take out the water. That wasn't
around in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
They would either bathe in a kind of
pot, a big pot that would catch all the
water,
or they would bathe outside in the sand.
Right?
And so, if you've just bathed and washed
your private parts and washed
everything, the water
that you just used, that rinsed off your
body, is still underneath you. You're
standing on that water.
And so, as a finality, he would leave
his feet for last, salallahu alayhi
wasallam.
So, he would wash his foot and move out
of the place where he was, and then wash
the other foot.
So, that his feet now are clean, and he
is not trailing any of the dirty water
from where he was
washing.
Now, does a person have to do that now?
We have drains.
The water underneath your feet is always
pure, because it is always being
s- cyc- cycled through the It's coming
out the shower head. Everything dirty is
going down the drain, right?
The answer to this is
yes and no. A person can do it out of
tradition, and that is fine, and that is
great, and that is better, in order to
keep that alive.
But, a person does not have to. They can
make wudu,
and when they reach the part of their
feet, they wash their feet, then they do
their head three times, work the water
into their scalp, then do the right, and
then the left, and then leave. That's
fine as well.
Either way
is correct with regards to making ghusl.
So, this is what the
ghusl is
in the way that the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam used to perform it. Now,
let's discuss the bare minimum of ghusl.
The bare minimum of ghusl is found in
Sahih al-Bukhari, in which the prophet
salallahu alayhi wasallam gave a
container of water to one of the
companions,
and said,
"Afrighhu
ala nafsika."
He said,
"Dump this water. bathe yourself in this
water.
What does that mean? Well, the scholars
say the bare minimum of ghusl
is the intention of ghusl
while the water reach every single part
of skin on your body.
Every crevice, everywhere.
And many scholars, including Imam
al-Bukhari, say as well the mouth and
the nose have to be included in that.
So, a bare minimum of ghusl bismillah,
let's say I'm in the ocean or I'm in a
swimming pool that's clean. Bismillah, I
dive under the water and then I rinse my
mouth and nose. That's it. That is
ghusl.
Or I'm in the shower, or I'm in, you
know, a
a bathtub or a jacuzzi, whatever it is.
Right?
That is the bare minimum.
But the best way to make ghusl is in the
way that I have just mentioned and
described
[Arabic recitation]
anha.
And so, this is enough for today.
Inshallah, next week
we may tie up some loose ends with
regards to ghusl, some misconceptions
about it, and then we will move on to
the manner in which the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam would stand
for prayer in front of his Lord,
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Aقول قولي هذا
واستغفر الله سبحانه وتعالى لي ولكم
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا علما
نافعا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وصلى اللهم
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين والسلام
عليكم.